a heat wave is searing its way through
Mexico one of the longest in years
officials say there have already been
deaths and the country's North is being
hit especially hard
tomorrow we'll also hit 42 or 43 degrees
and it will continue as forecasted for
10 days compared to the last 20 years we
haven't had such a long Heat Wave this
is why we're calling it atypical
it's even caused the country's Energy
Authority to issue a warning the
Mexico's power grid is close to its
capacity president Andres Manuel Lopez
obrador says there's nothing to worry
about
[Music]
we'd be the first to want to know what
was happening if there were blackouts
just imagine it's our responsibility
that we don't lack electricity so I say
to you all there's no problem
the local media have already reported
blackouts in a handful of States these
people are protesting the lack of power
in their neighborhood in the northern
city of Monterey
and it's not just people who are
struggling with the Heat this is Benito
a giraffe who lives in the Sierra
juarezu activists were already pushing
to get him moved now more so
I think that adapting a space for him
would be the best as it would be more
comfortable to Bear the weather that's
hitting our city the heat waves due to
continue for a few days more in the
north at least as this country struggles
to get through it Mexicans are used to
their Summers hot but now everyone's
just praying for the Reigns John Holman
Al Jazeera Mexico City